good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a lot happening in the
news here's one item that we noticed
canada canceled democracy last night and
the remarkable thing is no one in this
country seemed to notice that it
happened there was no outcry from our
political class as their friend justin
trudeau declared martial law in response
to an entirely peaceful protest from his
country's working class
our news media barely noted that it
happened weirdest of all the state
department which exists these days to
denounce such attackers of democracy as
hungary and poland
didn't say a single word as democracy in
canada ended
that's pretty weird if you think about
it canada is not some exotic faraway
land with an alien culture and an
unintelligible language it's not ukraine
canada is our neighbor it's our trading
partner canada is our closest ally on
earth it's probably part of our country
our vice president grew up in canada so
did half of our comedians and actors and
singers our border with canada is the
longest border in the world it stretches
more than 5 500 miles
so on every level we are deeply
intertwined with canada whether we
notice it or not what happens there
matters here
if nothing else it's a preview of what
will likely happen in the united states
so with that in mind you should know
that justin trudeau is no longer the
prime minister of canada justin trudeau
is canada's maximum leader
it's strong man it's cardio it's
potentate justin trudeau is the dictator
of canada
if you think that's an overstatement try
to think of another way to describe what
justin trudeau is now doing
for the first time in canada's history
trudeau has invoked what's known as the
emergencies act so the protests he is
facing hardly qualify as an emergency
but suddenly justin trudeau has the
power to crush all political opposition
to his rule and that's exactly what he's
doing trudeau has ended free speech in
canada he's banned free assembly
trudeau's government has shut down
political rallies and arrested his
political critics without probable cause
trudeau has instituted internal
passports that restrict travel within
canada to the politically obedient
canadians are no longer allowed to leave
their own country unless they obey
justin trudeau and if they don't obey
they could be bankrupted and destroyed
he now has the power to do that trudeau
has claimed the power to freeze the
financial assets of any canadian who
resists him no court order is required
to do this he just decides
justin trudeau can even dictate what you
do for a living and how you do it
today trudeau threatened to arrest tow
truck drivers who refused to tow the
trucks of protesters
is this really about stopping the spread
of coronavirus
no one in canada is even pretending that
it is anymore trudeau himself didn't
mention the risk of covid a single time
yesterday he's not worried about
unvaccinated truckers spreading a virus
should always worry about canadians
resisting his rule
that's why trudeau's government
announced yesterday they plan to
regulate cryptocurrency forever watch
we are broadening the scope of canada's
anti-money laundering laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
oh
the terrorist financing act so that was
a law passed to defeat al qaeda now it's
being used to stop law-abiding canadians
middle-class people students truck
drivers from protecting their earnings
from the total mismanagement of canada's
central bank
justin trudeau has wrecked the canadian
economy but thanks to the terrorist
financing act there's no escape from the
consequences canadians are going to have
to live with the consequences of justin
trudeau's fiscal recklessness whether
they want to or not otherwise they're
terrorists
it shouldn't surprise you that trudeau's
first move in the face of a trucker
protest was to clamp down on
cryptocurrency democrats will try this
in this country guaranteed they'll tell
us bitcoin is a russian plot cnn will
dutifully back them up watch it happen
but at the same time you've got to
wonder since we're speaking of terrorism
what happened to the actual terrorists
those do exist how is justin trudeau
treating them well let's see
a few years ago justin trudeau gave more
than 10 million dollars in taxpayer
money in a settlement to a
self-described al-qaeda soldier called
omar khadr
khadr murray murdered a u.s army
sergeant
now murdering a us army sergeant is bad
but it's not as bad as criticizing
justin trudeau so trudeau did not freeze
cotter's bank account instead he just
made him rich and moved on
when anti-christian arsonists burned
more than 50 catholic churches across
canada justin trudeau did not declare an
emergency instead he issued a statement
sympathizing with them quote it is fully
understandable trudeau said given the
shameful history we are all becoming
more aware of
the beginning to see how this works
in a dictatorship the only real crime is
opposing the regime
so how did all this happen so quickly in
a country as nice and moderate as canada
well it happened the way that it always
happened it happened with maximum
aggression and limited popular support
justin trudeau won re-election last year
with less than a third of the national
vote in fact he finished the election
behind his main competitor the
conservative party thanks to quirks in
the parliamentary system trudeau took
power anyway and he immediately began to
crack down on anyone who opposed him
trudeau had relatively few supporters
but they turned out to be the right
supporters they were the people with
power
the woman for example you just saw
announcing the crackdown on
cryptocurrency is canada's deputy prime
minister but before she was that she was
a long-time journalist including in our
country she used to write for the
washington post
she's currently married to a new york
times reporter why is that relevant well
because up and down this story you see
the starring role that media
organizations have played in the death
of canadian democracy
the other day for example somebody
hacked the database of the crowdfunding
website give fund go and then revealed
the names of people who donated to the
truckers protesting in ottawa
you got to ask yourself
who would have the tech savvy and the
political motive to do something like
that well state intelligence agencies
would in fact we can't really think of
anybody else it would certainly be
interesting to find out who did it it's
a big part of the story but media
companies seem curiously uninterested in
finding out who did it instead they
immediately started using this stolen
information to intimidate the donors
anyone who dared to send money to justin
trudeau's political opponents was
unmasked in public shamed and of course
inevitably threatened because that's
what happens
trudeau state tv channel the cbc has
been working on this retribution project
all day long they know who their enemies
are and they know who their master is
it's justin trudeau
but canada's national post newspaper is
doing the same thing the national post
is supposedly independent of the
government but they're still doing it
in this country vice media to its great
and eternal shame has been doing the
same thing
so what do all of these media companies
have in common
well they're all squarely on the side of
entrenched power against the population
they supposedly serve
that's the opposite of what journalism
was designed designed to do but at this
point it is the rule not just in the
united states but around the world
reporters and politicians in big
business all align against voters
against you have you noticed
earlier this week the cbc warned
canadians that the word freedom has
quote become common among far-right
groups
so only q anon wants freedom remember
that the next time you complain about
justin trudeau
media organizations have been agitating
against democracy for years now even as
they've posed loudly as its greatest
defenders in february of 2020 the
beginning of the pandemic vice media ran
this headline
anti-vaxxers are terrified the
government will enforce a vaccine for
coronavirus anti-vax groups on social
media are claiming that the spread of
the disease will lead to mandatory
vaccinations and unlimited surveillance
yeah
those conspiracy nuts
now that all that has actually happened
vice has not apologized and said vice is
helping justin trudeau to hurt anyone
who complains about it
in october of that same year 2020 the
cbc warned canadians about a quote
disinformation campaign that quote
falsely suggests canadians will be
forcibly sent to quarantine sites
a few months later as if on cue the
tribute government began forcibly
sending canadians to quarantine sites
but the cbc never apologized for quoting
what turned out to be disinformation
instead they set about enforcing justin
trudeau's latest decrees
they see that as their job
so by the way it is the so-called
academic community these are the
university professors who've been
granted lifetime job security precisely
so they can think for themselves freely
independent from government control
and yet in practice no one is more
controlled by the government than they
are
here's a professor from canada's
carleton university that's an
institution heavily funded by justin
trudeau telling cnn's viewers how
dangerous and immoral it is to criticize
justin trudeau in any way watch
i think it's important to remember that
at the core of this protest uh you know
it was never really about mandates in
the first place it's always been about a
small group of people who called for a
convoy who hold very uh anti-government
views and as well as kind of a racist
white supremacist views conspiratorial
world views
oh they hold anti-government views
that's the crime but isn't holding
anti-government views allowed in a
democracy
in fact isn't the measure of democratic
government that agreed to which sure
allowed to question the people in charge
well that used to be the definition of
democracy
it's not anymore certainly not on cnn
the cnn anchor who heard that just
nodded yes it is indeed a scary problem
when canadians disagree with justin
trudeau arrest them
on msnbc which is less subtle but a lot
more straightforward most of the time
they're telling justin trudeau to stop
with the half measures the problem with
canada is it's not authoritarian enough
time to get the stick and start hurting
people watch this
i do have to ask one question though
about the liberal prime minister in
canada
seriously i'm sorry i'm sorry if i'm a
mayor i'm a prime minister
your trucks
get in my city street
they're not going to stay there a week
no no no no they're not going to stay
there's going to be somebody with a
stick
and it's going to be banging on the
window it's going to say you got one of
two options you can move this thing or
we're going to cuff you and take you to
jail and we're going to pound this and
we're going to find your company so move
it or lose it
settle down tough guy there's going to
be someone there with a stick
it's interesting it's always the very
same people who call for violence it's
almost like
it excites them that's not a good sign
so clearly there is an appetite for
canadian style tyranny in this country
the question is how long till we get it
let's see this morning we learned that
american intelligence agencies are
trying to censor a financial website
called zero hedge
unnamed sources from joe biden's intel
community told the associated press off
the record of course that zero hedge was
quote spreading russian propaganda by
which they meant criticizing joe biden
we can't have that
so how long before they pull zero hedge
off the internet how long before they
try the same thing with joe biden's many
other critics in the media all of whom
we can tell you firsthand have also been
accused of working for vladimir putin
and when that does happen when these
voices are silenced what will we call it
then cnn will of course describe it as a
necessary national security measure but
it's not that it's tyranny
and by the way since when does the cia
get to decide what websites americans
read are there any civil libertarians
left in this country old-fashioned
liberals anyone what do they think of
this
maybe they don't notice it
in their defense it's hard to notice
sometimes with leaders like joe biden
and justin trudeau they don't look very
threatening they're not the hollywood
version of fascist look at justin
trudeau he's absurd
the 70s haircut all those little outfits
when he feels like playing dress-up
he doesn't look dangerous he looks
ridiculous
but maybe justin trudeau is smarter than
he looks
leaders like biden and trudeau avoid the
usual tells they don't use armies to
invade other countries for example
instead they promote color revolutions
and control foreign governments from
afar
that's exactly what they did in ukraine
which became a far more repressive place
once joe biden began running it and he
does run ukraine make no mistake
that's what they do this new class of
dictators sees his power incrementally
through the bureaucracy they never raise
their voices they don't wave their arms
they smile and they tell you they're
protecting democracy and public health
they praise diversity even as they
demand conformity they're entirely
passive aggressive
but they're no less dangerous one
morning you wake up and they've canceled
your job and seized your bank account
for the crime of disagreeing with them
this is the architecture of tyranny and
it's not just happening in canada it's
happening here in the united states it
will be used against us bet on it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else